regardez
paul j
m
des lésions merci d'en faire un très
large de lisbonne pour couru les logos
et puis bien sûr tous ensemble ne perdez
pas votre énergie et on va vous entends
dire on va gagner on va gagner on va
gagner et on va gagner
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs merci d'accueillir
et de faire un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour la première
prise de parole votre présidente de
région madame christine moran s'est
alors avant christelle morancé nous
allons avoir le coe le président de
votre comité de soutien à monsieur
françois blanchet que je vous demande
d'applaudir
et qui va vous dire un petit mot
merci
bien bonsoir à toutes et tous merci
merci d'être venus aussi nombreux ce
soir à mouilleron le captif pour faire
honneur à notre candidate qu'on est très
heureux d'accueillir très très heureux
d'accueillir ici valérie pécresse elle
est venu parler aux forces vives de la
vendée je peux vous dire que depuis le
début de l'après midi elle n'a pas
ménagé sa peine elle n'a pas ménagé son
temps pour rencontrer les vendéennes et
les vendéens alors je suis très heureux
de l'accueillir ici je voulais bien sûr
saluer tous les élus qui sont ici vous
me permettrait d'avoir un petit mot
particulier pour notre présidente de
région christelle marrant c'est qu'on
est très heureux d'accueillir je voulais
bien sûr saluer tous les parlementaires
les collègues conseillers régionaux les
conseillers départementaux tous les élus
tous les élus qui sont ici de notre
région et puis vous salue et tout et
tout je sais que vous menez des quatre
coins de la région du maine et loire
bien sûr de loire-atlantique de vendée
des deux sèvres
mon cher philippe voilà donc bienvenue à
vous toutes et tous
depuis cet après-midi et bien valérie
d'abord fait une séquence à mouilleron
avec bien sûr l'histoire de la vendée
avec delattre et clemenceau de deux
grands hommes bien sûr et puis ensuite
elle est venue sur le littoral à
saint-gilles-croix-de-vie pour
rencontrer les marins pêcheurs pour
rencontrer les agriculteurs et pour
rencontrer les acteurs économiques de
notre secteur et de notre département et
je peux vous dire qu'elle n'a pas ménagé
sa peine que tout le monde était
enchanté de cette séquence qu'elle a pu
discuter échanger avec les pêcheurs avec
les agriculteurs une femme enraciné sur
le terrain qui connaît parfaitement ses
dossiers bien loin de l'image que
voudrait nous montrer certains candidat
en manque d'audience et je peux vous
dire qu'on a une femme ancrée sur
terrain et vous pouvez l'applaudir parce
qu'elle connaît ses dossiers par coeur
et croyez moi elle a marqué des points
et puis cerise sur le gâteau elle a même
pu goûter la sardine de saint gilles
croix de vie n'est ce pas avec un petit
verre de vin de brême voilà et ça
c'était parfait voilà donc merci d'être
nombreux on a besoin de vous pendant
cette campagne on a besoin de vous
pendant les semaines qui viennent donc
on compte sur vous merci et je laisse la
parole à christelle morançais vous
pouvez l'applaudir très forte
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous je
suis très heureuse et très heureuse
d'être à vos côtés d'être à tes côtés ma
chère valérie et puis j'aimerais faire
un petit complément parce que je pense
qu'il ya aussi dans cette salle des
sarthois et des mayennais
oui j'en ai
bien j'aimerais y les vendéens mais ça a
été cité tout à l'heure
bien j'aimerais bien évidemment salué
l'ensemble des parlementaires les
députés sénateurs salue tout
particulièrement les députés de de
vendée cher bruno cher didier cher
reims ni fille annick excuse moi ça lui
est bien évidemment l'ensemble des
conseillers régionaux qui sont présents
très nombreux saluer
quelle équipe
salut les conseillers départementaux
également
ils sont aussi nombreux
saluer l'ensemble des maires qui sont
présents l'ensemble des élus et vous
saluer toutes et tous
ma chère valérie bienvenus bienvenue
dans la région des pays de la loire
bienvenu ici en vendée tué dans une
région où ici les hommes et les femmes
sont courageux
travailleur est optimiste tu es dans une
région où c'est le taux de chômage le
plus faible de france
tu es dans une région où en 2021 nous
avons eu le nombre de créations
d'entreprises le plus important de
france
mais tu es aussi dans une région où il
ya cet équilibre réussite économique et
grande solidarité et ça c'est une vraie
fierté et puis bien évidemment tu es
dans une région où les gens vont de
l'avant m ce collectif et j'ai le
souvenir pendant cette crise on était
tous main dans la main quel que soit
d'ailleurs les sensibilités politiques
pour accompagner pour aider nos petites
entreprises nos artisans nos commerçants
et tué dans une région à ton image
valérie à ton image et tu es ici chez
toi
mon engagement mon engagement politique
ce n'est pas contre des hommes et des
femmes ce n'est pas contre des idées mon
engagement en politique
c'est pour et notamment dans cette
campagne présidentielle c'est pour une
femme comme toi valérie qui a du courage
la détermination
et puis cette envie de faire et j'aime
j'ai rajouté souvent je le dis cette
expression c'est une femme avec une main
de fer dans un gant de velours
mon engagement donc c'est pour une femme
pour des idées et des idées que nous
partageons toutes les deux et notamment
permettez-moi de d'évoquer trois défis
trois défis qui sont devant nous et je
sais qu'ils tiennent particulièrement à
coeur l'emploi l'emploi c'est le combat
des combats nous étions à l'instant à
une table ronde à saint gilles croix de
vie y est avec des chefs d'entreprise
avec des agriculteurs avec des pêcheurs
et tous les jours
tous les jours on est interpellé par ces
entreprises quelle que soit leur taille
commerçants artisans tpe pme grands
groupes quel que soit leur secteur
d'activité parce qu'il ya plus de
métiers en tension c'est partout et quel
que soit quel que soit le secteur
géographique où nos chefs d'entreprise
aujourd'hui peine à recruter et pourtant
et pourtant taux de chômage est encore
élevé on n'est pas sûr du plein emploi
le plein emploi c'est ici en vendée aux
herbiers avec 3% de chômage s'est pas à
7 ou 8%
et c'est pas non plus quand un jeune un
jeune sur cinq aujourd'hui en france est
au chômage ce n'est pas acceptable
deuxième défi c'est celui de la jeunesse
et je sais que le partage alors c'est
peut-être
ce côté notre côté mère de famille où
notre volonté aussi d'aller de l'avant
d'agir et surtout de préparer l'avenir
parce que préparer l'avenir c'est avant
tout pour la jeunesse que je salue et
que j'ai vue relativement nombreux ce
soir merci de votre présence
et cette jeunesse
cette jeunesse elle est formidable il
faut lui faire confiance
bien évidemment c'est ce que tu proposes
notamment avec les savoirs fondamentaux
notamment au niveau 2 de l'école
primaire savoir lire compter écrire
c'est l'essentiel et puis aussi d'ouvrir
le champ des possibles il n'y a pas une
seule voix il y en a plusieurs
l'apprentissage vous connaissez mon
engagement sur l'apprentissage
la voie professionnelle
la voie technologique ou général quelle
que soit la voie c'est d'ouvrir ce champ
des possibles pour la jeunesse et puis
le troisième défi la transition
écologique tu en as parlé tout à l'heure
et là encore la transition écologique ce
n'est pas réservé un parti politique la
transition écologique
c'est notre responsabilité collective
bien évidemment les temps et régions et
départements
le bloc communal bien évidemment les
entreprises nos agriculteurs qui font
déjà un travail extraordinaire et puis
tout un chacun sur des gestes du
quotidien mais l'écologie que tu portes
toi valérie c'est celle de la croissance
c'est celle des projets et c'est celle
qui se fera avec les entreprises et puis
pour conclure
valérie tu peux bien évidemment compter
sur
chacun d'entre nous pour être à tes
côtés il ne faut rien lâcher il reste
que quelques semaines vous devez tous
vous mobiliser pour faire gagner valérie
merci
vous pouvez applaudir votre présidente
de région porte parole national de la
campagne de valérie pécresse présidente
de la région des pays de la loire madame
christine oser
et pour accueillir maintenant vous allez
accueillir quelqu'un que vous connaissez
bien ici c'est le sénateur de la vendée
et puis bien sûr président du groupe au
sénat les républicains
merci de faire un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour monsieur bruno
retailleau
[Applaudissements]
c'est loupé vous auriez dû dire valérie
valérie valérie
mes chers amis bercy vous êtes venus
nombreux
plus nombreux que je le pensais et c'est
important parce qu'on avait on va avoir
besoin de vous de chacun d'entre vous je
voudrais saluer tous les élus qui sont
là ils sont nombreux je voudrais saluer
les élus de vendée notamment les
sénateurs bien sûr didier bien sûr
indique mais il ya aussi d'autres
sénateurs d'autres départements jeu les
englobe tous de la région mais aussi d'à
côté de la région bien sûr christelle
qui vient de vous faire un beau discours
merci christelle pour ton optimisme pour
se vend à la fois féminin mais aussi
qu'ils portent vers l'avenir et puis je
voudrais aussi saluer tous les élus
municipaux départementaux régionaux ils
sont nombreux aussi et bien sûr les
candidats j'envoie quelques-uns qui
seront et qui défendront nos couleurs
aux législatives parce qu'il ya les
élections présidentielles mais il faudra
une fois que valérie sera élu lui donner
bien sûr une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale parce que c'est important
quand on veut gouverner bien sûr et je
compte sur chacun d'entre vous là aussi
valérie
franchement est vraiment suis très
heureux de t'accueillir ce soir ici en
vendée je suis très heureux d'accueillir
sur un périple qui t'a amené tu l'a peut
être pas vu mais de mouilleron à
mouilleron mouilleron en pareds cher
jacky cher philippe à mouilleron le
captif
en passant par saint gilles mon cher
françois
la terre de vendée l'enracinement et
puis la mer le grand large les horizons
qui s'ouvrent parce que c'est la vendée
ce déplacement cette visite en vendée
elle a du sens hélas beaucoup de sens
elle a du sens parce que la vendée c'est
une terre qui a du caractère
comme toi
ici on ne faiblit pas
ici on ne recule pas ici mes amis
on se bat on ne lâche rien ce sont des
qualités qui sont les tiennes valérie
aujourd'hui et demain tu y en aura
besoin pour gouverner
une campagne présidentielle
c'est escalader l'everest
tu as ses qualités et j'ai pensé dans la
voiture en venant je me disais que
finalement tu es sans doute la plus
vendéenne de toutes les franciliennes et
les corréziennes réunis c'est une grande
qualité
[Applaudissements]
mais puisqu'on entoure ce soir avec tous
nos espoirs que tu portes je voudrais
dire que tu incarnes aussi deux exigent
deux exigences qui nous parle à nous les
vendéens ou même les ligériens
christelle
deux exigences qui nous parle parce que
ce sont celles de la vendée la
combativité le courage mais aussi
l'unité l'unité française
d'abord la combativité mes amis vous
avez pu remarquer ces derniers jours que
de tous les candidats la plus attaquée
c'est valérie pécresse
mais finalement je sais c'est dur et
c'est violent et c'est brutal mais tu
t'y attendais mais c'est finalement
normal et pardon presque ration
parce que c'est toi qui auprès de tous
les autres candidats représentent le
principal danger
le danger pour emmanuel macron
c'est valérie pécresse c'est le danger
d'une retraite
c'est le danger d'une retraite anticipée
mes amis parce qu'il sait parfaitement
le président de la république tu es la
seule à pouvoir le battre en duel dans
un second tour la seule
mais tu es aussi le danger pour marine
le pen et pour eric zemmour bien
évidemment
tu représente pour eux le danger de la
crédibilité face à leur démagogie qui
n'a pas de bornes de marine le pen on le
savait et nous a tous fait sur l'euro
sur les retraites j'en passe et des
meilleurs jeux c'est d'ailleurs plus
trop quoi vous dire sur son propre
programme mais eric zemmour je m'étais
dit c'est un intellectuel il va se tenir
à l'écart de ces facilités et puis non
il y cède lui aussi un exemple dix mille
euros par enfant né dans la ruralité moi
je suis un enfant de la ruralité et les
chers amis on a du bon sens elle vous
croyez qu'il est plus facile quand on
est mère de famille avec un petit
salaire d'élever un enfant dans une
ville non c'est toujours la même
difficulté et moi je me bats pour comme
toi d'ailleurs pour une vraie politique
familiale pour ce qu'on appelle
l'universalité des allocations
familiales qu'on soit en ville un enfant
né en ville où un enfant né en campagne
il a les mêmes droits parce que les
familles doivent les élever avec le même
courage
[Applaudissements]
alors oui tu es dans cette campagne
la femme à abattre la cible principale
je veux pas dire que ça me plaît mais ce
qui me plaît c'est de voir résister dans
l'adversité là
il ya quelque chose de vendéens j'en
parlais tout à l'heure c'est un peu le
message de mouilleron de
mouilleron-en-pareds avec clemenceau et
et jean delattre mais c'est aussi le
courage des vendéens tu sais valérie et
si je suis athée côté c'est parce que
j'ai toujours considéré qu'en politique
le courage c'était la toute première
qualité parce que c'est ce courage c'est
cette qualité qui rend possible toutes
les autres qualités vous pouvez être
intelligent si vous n'avez pas le
courage ça ne sert à rien vous pouvez
avoir fait les plus belles études sans
courage ça ne sert à rien oui le courage
c'est ce qu'on demande à une femme
politique ou un homme politique
notamment quand tu vas devoir relever un
pays qui a été ainsi abîmé par le
quinquennat des mails macron le courage
c'est le courage de dire et c'est le
courage de faire le courage de dire la
vérité sur le bilan des macros je ne
veux pas être long voilà un homme qui
nous avait promis de tout changer il
aura tout continuer parce qu'il n'a rien
réformer tous les présidents de
républiques avant lui depuis trente ans
on fait une réforme de retraites pour
garantir le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités il est le seul depuis 30 ans à
ne pas avoir eu ce courage il l'appelait
la mère des réformes et bien cette mère
des réformes il s'est couché il ne l'a
pas fait voilà un homme qui nous avait
promis un monde nouveau cure de jouvence
jeune il était et qui à la première
difficulté
à ses vieux réflexes ses vieilles
ficelles
qu'utilise la vieille garde politicienne
française depuis des décennies dès qu'il
ya un problème il ya de la dépense
publique des cas une crise il ya un
artifice de communication
c'est ça le quinquennat de macron et il
faudra le dire il fera le dénoncer tu es
la seule à avoir ce courage
toi tu as le courage justement de dire
de dire que tant qu on dépensera
toujours plus tant qu'on travaillera
toujours moins on ne pourra pas sortir
la france de son déclin de son
déclassement
[Applaudissements]
et toi seul tu as le courage de dire
aussi aux français avec franchise de
dire aux français que tant qu'on
accueillera toujours plus con assimilera
toujours moins tant qu'on ne relèvera
pas la fierté française dans le coeur de
chaque jeune français eh bien on ne
soignera pas cette angoisse française
cette angoisse qu'ont les français du
bas des classes moyennes populaire de la
grande dépossession
culturelle identitaire
merci de le dire merci de porter
spéciale valérie
le courage de dire et le courage de
faire
parce qu'on en a marre des bonimenteurs
ces bonimenteurs qui n'ont pas ce
courage de faire ce que tu veux faire
parce que pour eux ils ont des mots
forts à proportion que leurs actes sont
faibles bien sûr mes amis qu'est ce que
vous préférez est ce que vous préférez
un président de la république
qui fait des grands discours
tonitruants contre l'islamisme et qu'ils
aient la moindre difficulté qui lorsque
le sénat
gérard didier cher annick vote un
amendement pour interdire le voile sur
les terrains de sport parce qu'on
considère que l'olympisme que le sport
c'est un rêve d'égalité c'est un rêve
d'universalité
bien dès que nous nous votons lui
emmanuel re mc ren refuse cet amendement
est ce que vous préférez ce président de
république ou est-ce que vous préférez
cette présidence de région qui avec
courage a interdit chez elle le burqini
dites moi
[Applaudissements]
alors si vous en avez assez
de tous ces hommes qui glosent si vous
voulez une femme qui ose
si vous voulez une fable une présidente
qui fasse le job plutôt qu'un président
qui fasse le show
si
si vous en avez assez de ces
bonimenteurs de ces beaux parleurs qui
sont bien souvent de tristes acteurs
alors vous êtes venu au bon endroit
bienvenu ici à mouilleron autour de
valérie pécresse choisissez valérie
pécresse
[Applaudissements]
sans tour viendra sont orientera
le courage c'est à dire la combativité
mais aussi l'unité tu n'es pas seulement
valérie une fâcheuse
qui est aussi une combattante
mais tu es aussi une rassembleuse
tu es une rassembleuse parce que tu as
compris ce qu'était la france la france
qui est une oeuvre mes amis collective
une oeuvre ancienne
comme le disait le général de gaulle une
oeuvre qui nous vient du fond des âges
mais une oeuvre fragile une oeuvre
fragile qu'on doit préserver une oeuvre
fragile parce que la france est un
combat toujours recommencée contre la
tentation des divisions et c'est au fond
le message que nous adressent les hommes
de mouilleron de mouilleron-en-pareds
clemenceau et delattre ce visage natale
qui les a vu naître tous les deux
de grandes figures vendéenne mais
surtout de tradition française si
différentes l'une blanche l'autre bleue
l'incroyant au ciel et l'autre n'y
croyais pas une tradition de plume une
tradition des p et pourtant une seule
france un seul amour de la france le
même patriotisme exigeant
incandescent qui porte et qui proclame
l'amour des siens mais qui refuse la
haine des autres c'est notre idéal à
nous vendéen français c'est cet idéal
qu'un jour le jour de la victoire de
1918 à la tribune de l'assemblée
nationale
clemenceau
avait en s'écriant ans époux moments
décrits sur l'idéal français hier
soldats de dieu aujourd'hui soldats de
l'humanité la france sera toujours le
soldat de l'idéal et c'est ce que nous
voulons à tes côtés relevé retrouver ma
chère valérie 7 idéal français cet idéal
qui nous manque tant pour terminer ce
que je veux dire de façon solennelle ici
au centre de la vendée géographique et
historique on dit souvent que une
élection présidentielle c'est la
rencontre
d'une femme que tu es un peuple que tu
aimes peuple français je pense que pour
cette élection ce sera beaucoup plus
beaucoup beaucoup plus ce sera sans
doute la rencontre
du peuple français avec son destin les
amis quel destin choisissons-nous
quel peuple voulons nous être
un peuple en déclin un peuple de rien un
peuple qui ne réforment leur est rien un
peuple qui ne se reconnaîtrait dans rien
dans cette histoire il dans sa culture
un peuple qui pèseraient pour rien dans
le monde est pour rien non plus en
europe en afrique ou est ce que nous
voulons avec valérie être à nouveau ce
grand peuple ce grand peuple de france
libre fier qui puise dans ses racines
dans son identité aussi
la force de ses lancers de se porter à
l'avant garde de la modernité parce que
notre france à nous ça n'est pas un
chagrin notre france à nous ça n'est pas
une nostalgie la france que nous voulons
avec valérie la france que nous aimons
c'est bien sûr la france de clovis de
saint-louis la france de clemenceau la
france de zola aussi mais aussi la
france deux pays la france que nous
voulons est celle que nous aimons c'est
bien sûr je reste mais c'est pour nous
dans notre famille politique le général
de gaulle c'est aussi la france de tous
les artistes la gouaille de piaf la
gueule de gabin peut être aussi les
mélodies aujourd'hui de clara luciani
qui vient de reporter les lecteurs de
musique c'est ça notre france à nous
c'est celle qui nous porte c'est la
france que dans tu veux relever la
fierté cet idéal français alors avec toi
mais cher à bille dans quelques semaines
ça ne doit pas être ni les médias ni les
sondeurs qui doivent faire cette
élection
chacun d'entre vous vous personnellement
vous avec vos voisins vos amis dans vos
familles nous allons emmener vers la
victoire valérie parce qu'elle le mérite
parce que ce message qu'elle porte c'est
un message d'espérance c'est le message
de la france merci à toi venez
vous pouvez applaudir monsieur bruno
retailleau
que vous connaissez bien
et maintenant je vous demande de vous
lever pour faire un triomphe à une femme
authentique celui là qui sera la
prochaine présidente de la république
merci le caractère d'applaudissements
pour madame valérie pécresse
valérie valérie valérie valérie baleri
valérie
merci merci mes chers amis merci à tous
leurs gènes petit j'ai une petite un
petit pense-bête quand même parce que
pour remercier tous ceux qui sont venus
à mes côtés aujourd'hui si en vendée est
d'abord je voudrais remercier bruno
retailleau pour son accueil et son
formidable discours moi ce que j'aime
chez bruno vous savez ce que j'aime
c'est bruno c'est sa solidité c'est sa
fidélité c'est son amitié et ses
convictions parce que vous savez quand
on n'a pas de conviction on est comme la
plume au vent et des convictions
chevillées au corps bruno les a il a un
enracinement dans cette terre de vendée
mais il a aussi cette intelligence de
ceux qui ont beaucoup lu de ceux qui ont
beaucoup écrit et vous le savez il
défend des valeurs qui me sont chères
des valeurs d'ordre et des valeurs de
liberté et je voulais te dire bono que
je suis très touché et très sensible de
ton amitié de ta fidélité
alors bruno a des valeurs mais votre
présidente de région crise tellement
c'est on a aussi
et surtout l'envié chevillée au corps de
faire de votre région la plus belle de
france et vous la connaissez rien ne
l'arrêtera
alors je vais pas me prononcer sur le
fait de savoir si les pays de la loire
sont la plus belle région de france que
je ne vais pas me faire des ennemis ce
soir
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'elle l'a
dit un plus faible taux de chômage de
france
et puis une région absolument magnifique
une région industrielle une région
entreprenante une région côtière une
région avec des paysages une région avec
la douceur de vivre
donc effectivement tu as beaucoup de
chance christelle mais vous savez depuis
quelques jours il semble que je sois la
femme à abattre il semble que je sois
terriblement attaquez vous avez dans les
campagnes dans les campagnes et là quand
la compagne présidentielle est la plus
difficile dans les campagnes il y a des
bourrasques il y a des bon il ya des
mauvais moments mais ce que je voulais
vous dire c'est que moi je suis comme un
marin vendée je suis comme un marais
vendéen et moi je trace ma route et
quand le vent est contraire eh bien je
continue et je ne dévie pas de mon cap
alors alors il ya il ya certains qui
voudraient me caricaturer qui voudrait
faire de moi un portrait qui n'est pas
le mien
et c'est assez intéressant parce que je
crois christelle que c'était arrivé
aussi et je crois que pendant les
régionales toi aussi on a voulu
expliquer que tu n'étais pas la femme
que tout le monde ici connaît et tu as
eu une réaction d'indignation très forte
qui a touché tous les habitants des pays
de la loire et tu as dit
je ne suis pas cette femme là et je vous
mets au défi choisissez quelqu'un
d'autre et je crois que c'était ça a été
un cri ça a été un cri qui a été
entendue dans toute la france et je
crois que ça a été le début d'un vrai
sursaut des électeurs des pays de la
loire qui se sont dit mais pourquoi on
l'attaquent et pourquoi on la caricature
alors aujourd'hui moi je vous le dis moi
j'ai des convictions je suis une
gaulliste vous me connaissez je suis
d'une gaulliste social ça veut dire quoi
être une gaulliste social ça veut dire
aimer passionnément la france est
détesté viscéralement les injustices et
bien voilà valérie pécresse c'est ça
alors voilà
aujourd'hui il y à de nombreux élus qui
sont venus et je voudrais vraiment tous
les remercier remercier didier mandelli
le sénateur de la vendée avec lequel je
travaille sur les transports remercier
philippe mouillé fidèle des fidèles et
qui est notre meilleur spécialiste du
handicap nous sommes venus ensemble
philippe il y a quelques mois ici en
vendée pour rendre hommage aux
missionnaires au père mère qui venait de
se faire assassiner et nous sommes des
routes et nous étions dans le marais
poitevin et nous sommes dérouté pour
venir lui rendre hommage c'était un
moment extrêmement émouvant et nous
avons rencontré sa famille et nous avons
vécu la douleur de cette famille face à
ce crime absolument abjecte et nous
avons vu aussi
la solidarité de la communauté vendéenne
et à quel point en vendée tout le monde
tout le monde se tient les coudes et à
quel point tout le monde est solidaire
alors merci philippe merci à laurence
garnier sénatrice de la haute loire qui
est ma porte parole régionale
merci à stéphane pieds noirs qui lui
aussi est bon orateur sénateur du maine
et loire merci à louis jean de nicolaÿ
qui nous vient de la sarthe
alors blain député du maine-et-loire à
gibert favreau sénateurs des deux sèvres
merci aux anciens parlementaires
dominique caillaud louis guédon andré
trillard qui sont parmi nous aussi
merci à franck louvrier qui nous vient
de la baule et merci à tous les maires
de vendée et
à françois blanchet qui nous a
accueillis à saint gilles croix de vie
et merci d'être tous autour de moi ce
soir alors j'étais ce matin vous le
savez dans un petit village vendéen et
sans ce petit village vendéen sonné deux
grandes figures de l'histoire de france
georges clemenceau et le maréchal de
lattre de tassigny et il incarne
ensemble ils incarnent la france il
incarne comme l'a dit bruno retailleau
ceux qui croient au ciel ceux qui n'y
croient pas il incarne la france bleu la
france blanche mais surtout il incarne
le courage de ces hommes qui savent que
la victoire s'arrache à la toute fin le
père la victoire clemenceau le maréchal
de lattre de rhin et danube ce sont des
combattants c'est ce que disait
clemenceau il disait moi je veux que la
république se défendent mais pas par les
gesticulations et les vociférations
et bien on va laisser gesticuler et
vociférer les commentateurs et nous on
va proposer un vrai projet pour la
france et je vous le dis vendéen vous
qui êtes un peuple de navigateurs vous
qui êtes un peuple d'entrepreneurs vous
qui êtes un peuple de combattants vous
qui êtes un peuple de france nous allons
ensemble ce soir
parler de notre france alors parler de
la france c'est voir une france qui est
à la croisée de son destin
là aussi bruno la vie à la croisée de
son destin est ce que demain nous serons
encore la septième puissance mondiale
nous avons déjà reculé d'une place
est-ce que nous serons encore la
septième puissance mondiale est ce que
demain nous serons
encore une puissance souveraine ou bien
ce que nous serons vassale des etats
unis comptoir de la chine aujourd'hui la
question c'est que sera la france quelle
sera sa place demain et que seront les
français est ce que nous aurons encore
notre mode de vie est ce que nous serons
encore unis est-ce que nous serons
encore une nation avec des français qui
veulent vie vivre ensemble et avoir un
destin commun vous vous souvenez de ce
qu'a dit gérard collomb il a dit
aujourd'hui les français vivent
côte-à-côte j'espère que demain ils ne
vivront pas face à face alors le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons
françois hollande emmanuel macron qui
ont laissé depuis dix ans s'abîmer la
france s'abîme et la france avec une
dette colossale
qu'emmanuel vague macron veut léguer à
nos enfants ce matin un rapport de la
cour des comptes qui a dit que cette
dette cette dette il fallait qu'on
commence à la rembourser on est en train
aujourd'hui de transférer nos dépenses
sur nos enfants c'est complètement
amoral
la dette la perte de compétitivité de la
france un rapport hier qui a montré que
notre pays perdait sa compétitivité et
puis il y à l'école de la république qui
se fient sur la santé qui est à bout de
souffle et puis il y à la montée des
violences et puis il y a aussi ses flux
migratoires incontrôlés qui sont une
vraie bérézina migratoires et on le sait
bien une immigration incontrôlée et une
intégration ratée ça peut disloqué une
nation alors oui mes amis va falloir
refaire nation et moi je vous propose un
projet un projet qui s'appelle nouvelle
france nouvelle france parce que la
france est éternel
mais une nouvelle parce que le monde de
l'après covin ne sera pas le même que
celui d'aujourd'hui parce que les
français aspirent à un nouvel élan parce
que les français aspirent à de nouvelles
libertés et je crois qu'il va falloir
que nous les leur donnions alors ma
nouvelle france elle est souveraine elle
est souveraine elle se dresse droite
dans la compétition mondiale des nations
ma france elle est souveraine et elle se
laisse pas humilier en russie en
australie ou au mali ma france
elle dit qu'au sahel
la mission de lutte contre l'islamisme
n'est pas terminée et que certes nous
avons 58 soldats
qui ont payé le prix du sang pour
protéger le mali mais que nous ne
pouvons pas rester dans un pays qui ne
veut pas de nous alors on va réorganiser
la mission val a réorganisé au sahel
nous resterons au sahel pour protéger le
continent africain et par-delà protéger
le monde et nous rendrons hommage à nos
soldats parce que c'est eux qui protège
à la fois l'afrique mais aussi qui nous
protège alors notre france elle sera
souveraine elle sera souveraine dans son
agriculture elle sera souveraine dans
son industrie
notre france je la veux souveraine y
compris quand nous écoutons nos pêcheurs
qui nous disent que le bric site les a
spolié leurs droits de pêche je ne
laisserai pas tomber les pêcheurs de
vendée et nous irons dire aux
britanniques
qu'on ne peut pas qu'on ne peut pas
trahir des engagements quand on les
prend alors notre france elle sera
souveraine aussi à ses frontières vous
le savez
moi je crois qu'il va falloir prendre
des mesures très importantes je ferai
voter un référendum une loi sur
l'immigration
et dans cette loi il y aura des quotas
migratoires c'est quoi le principe est
bien le principe c'est un pays
qui reprend pas ces clandestins c'est
zéro vise à 0 bizarre et on choisit qui
en accueille ont choisi qui en accueille
le parlement chaque année votre à le
nombre de visas qu'on donne à chaque
pays mais avec ceux donnant donnant et
pas ailleurs et par ailleurs pour venir
en france pour être accueilli en france
il faudra passer un examen de français
et il faudra prouver son adhésion aux
valeurs de la république
parce que nous devons accueillir
nous devons accueillir des étrangers qui
viennent parce qu'il nous aime parce
qu'ils nous aiment et parce qu'ils
veulent s'intégrer et puis la
souveraineté c'est aussi de l'ordre de
l'ordre dans la rue toutes les figures
d'autorité mes chers amis aujourd'hui
sont bafoués dans notre pays ce sont les
maires ce sont les professeurs ce sont
les pompiers ce sont les forces de
l'ordre alors oui emmanuel macron a
failli quand il a admis qu'il y avait
des violences policières un président ne
devrait jamais dire ça parce que c'est
admettre que la police est violente non
notre police n'est pas violente il peut
y avoir des dérapages
individuels
mais notre police est l'une des plus
contrôlé du monde donc ça n'est pas
acceptable de dire ça et ça me met
évidemment l'autorité de nos forces de
l'ordre alors moi je vous le dis je
serai indéfectiblement au soutien de nos
forces de l'ordre et je ferais
[Applaudissements]
je mettrai en oeuvre un vrai plan orsec
pour notre justice parce que le vrai
problème aujourd'hui de la france c'est
la justice qui est noyé qui n'arrivent
plus à juger dans les délais il ya des
années de délais judiciaires aujourd'hui
on a besoin d'un plan orsec pour notre
justice on a besoin de recruter des
milliers de magistrats on a besoin de
créer des milliers de places de prison
aujourd'hui une vraie politique de
sécurité
ça ne peut pas être une politique sans
sanction sanctions rapides sanctions
exécuté
impunité 0 c'est mon projet
quand le président de la république et
giflé ses comparutions immédiates
incarcération immédiate
et bien moi je voudrais que le même
degré de sécurité soit apportée à tous
les français
alors une france souveraine c'est aussi
une france qui prend à bras le corps la
situation de l'école l'école c'est la
fabrique de la france l'école c'était
notre fierté et aujourd'hui c'est notre
défaite on a laissé depuis des années et
baisser le niveau de notre école est
aujourd'hui elle est devenue une école
des inégalités scolaires les plus
grandes d'europe nous sommes un pays dit
mobilité sociale il faut six générations
un fils d'ouvrier aujourd'hui pour
devenir cadres c'est ça la situation est
ce qu'on se résigne à cette situation à
ce qu'on se résigne à cette immobilité
sociale moi jamais jamais alors aux
affaires la nation éducative la nation
éducative c'est un projet où je vais
vous demander tous de vous mobiliser
pour notre école je veux un sursaut
national et ça commencera par des
fondamentaux lire écrire compter les
mathématiques le français
avec un examen à la fin du primaire
avant l'entrée en sixième pour vérifier
que tout va bien et on mettra fin au
collège uniforme parce que le collège
uniforme et bien c'est le creusement des
inégalités
ceux qui n'arriveront pas à passer
correctement l'examen à l'entrée en 6ème
rentreront dans des sixièmes de
consolidation airs front du français des
maths parce que ça sert à rien
d'apprendre la physique et l'anglais à
des enfants qui savent pas lire écrire
compter il faut pas les emmener vers
l'échec
et puis on valorisera les filières
professionnelles tout à l'heure j'étais
avec des pme de vendée qui me disait que
à la fin de la troisième ils veulent que
les jeunes puissent rentrer en
apprentissage ils ont souvent 14 ans et
aujourd'hui c'est pas légal de les faire
entrer en apprentissage
on ne peut pas faire attendre un jeune
qui est motivé et qui a envie il faut
qu'on puisse leur permettre d'aller en
apprentissage sous statut scolaire et
puis on confiera aux régions
l'enseignement professionnel parce que
il faut revaloriser cet enseignement
professionnel en lien avec les
entreprises d'un territoire et les
régions seront le fer elles seront
orientées les jeunes et puis comme je
veux que chaque enfant de france et sa
chance quelle que soit son origine
quelle que soit son milieu social et
bien nous créerons une réserve éducative
nationale nous feront revenir les
professeurs retraités nous feront
revenir des étudiants et nous leur
demanderons nous les rémunérons pour
qu'ils puissent faire du soutien
scolaire gratuit pour les familles je
veux
l'égalité des chances et l'exigence
c'est ça l'école de la république
alors dans cette nouvelle france
souveraine il y a des choses qu'il va
falloir protéger il va falloir protéger
l'écologie
l'environnement notre planète et oui les
jeunes nous le disent
l'urgence climatique nous devons être au
rendez vous alors là encore emmanuel
macron a failli
aucun des objectifs des accords de paris
n'est respectée aujourd'hui par la
france or quand on est amoureux de la
france on est amoureux de ses paysages
on est amoureux de sa de sa nature de sa
faune de sa flore on sait que la planète
on en hérite pas on l'empruntons à nos
enfants il va falloir la leur rendre
hélas leur rende plus belle la leur
rendre intacte et je sais et bruno que
tu est
profondément attaché à cette idée de
l'écologie comme une
à l'heure l'écologie c'est une valeur
c'est pas une idéologie c'est pas une
idéologie l'écologie c'est des solutions
c'est pas une punition c'est pas des
interdictions et moi jamais je ne
poserai l'écologie à l'économie et
jamais je ne poserai l'écologie à
l'homme voilà nous nous allons défendre
une vraie écologie humaniste et ça il
faut la protéger protéger l'écologie
protéger l'environnement protéger la
planète protéger aussi notre santé
protéger notre santé
aujourd'hui mes chers amis cinq millions
de français vivent sans médecin traitant
c'est ça la situation de la france nous
sommes devenus un désert médical
nous avons moins de 100000 généralistes
alors il va falloir là aussi
complètement reprendre les choses en
main et là aussi c'est toujours et
encore le bilan des manuels macron ce
bilan auquel il veut échapper mais nous
nous allons réparer notre santé alors
oui comment nous allons faire eh bien
nous allons faire un choc de formation
formé beaucoup plus de professionnels je
veux 25000 soignante plus à l'hôpital je
veux que les médecins généralistes il
fasse une est 4e année d'études de
spécialité et qu' on est près de 4000
jeunes généralistes qui arrivent dans
les territoires car ans et pendant un an
dans les maisons médicales pour venir
s'occuper
des français
et puis je veux aussi faire des
alliances territorial de santé je veux
que les régions soient temps en charge
avec les départements et que l'on fasse
travailler ensemble tous les
professionnels de santé l'hôpital public
l'hôpital privé les médecins les
dentistes les infirmiers les sages
femmes et puis qu'on leur confie plus de
responsabilités vous savez il n'ya pas
de désert pharmaceutique en france 1
donc ça veut dire que on peut aussi
confier des missions aux infirmiers
expérimentés aux pharmaciens aux sages
femmes il faut faire confiance faux
délégués il faut sauver
entre santé et puis
et puis il va falloir aussi protéger la
famille la famille c'est une valeur qui
a été redécouverte pendant cette
pandémie redécouverte par tous les
français pourquoi et bien parce que
c'est le lieu de l'affection et que
quand on est malade eh bien on se rend
encore plus compte à quel point nos
proches comptent pour nous et il y a eu
ce drame ce drame qu'ont vécu tous les
français de ne pas pouvoir aller voir
leurs aînés pendant la crise pendant le
confinement et parfois même ne pas
pouvoir les accompagner ceux qui sont
partis et bien moi je vous le dis plus
jamais aucun français quelle que soit la
situation sanitaire ne sera privé
d'aller embrasser nos aînés
alors oui je veux être la candidate des
familles chers amis je pense que je vais
être la seule
parce que françois hollande emmanuel
macron détricoter la politique familiale
qu'on fait maintenant 10 % de bébés en
moins qu'il ya dix ans or moi je veux
que dans cette nouvelle france cette
france de l'après coville les jeunes aux
qu'ils osent entreprendre qu'ils osent
faire des études qu'ils osent acheter un
logement je ferai des prêts à taux zéro
pour
sur tout le territoire pour les aider à
venir dans les bourgs dans les villages
il ya une nouvelle aspiration à une
nouvelle qualité de vie aujourd'hui chez
les jeunes je veux l'encourager c'est
une chance extraordinaire pour la
ruralité ça va permettre de rénover tous
nos centres bourgs et c'est ça une
ruralité vivante une réalité une réalité
vibrante donc on va aider nos jeunes à
réaliser leurs projets et parmi les
projets il ya aussi celui de fonder une
famille et pour ça eh bien on va les
aider on va les aider financièrement
avec des allocations familiales
universelles
dès le premier enfant
et puis la famille c'est aussi aux aînés
et là aussi on ne peut pas rester
sans rien dire face au scandale absolu
de la gestion de certains ehpad comment
en est on arrivé là
la question mérite une enquête
approfondie et des sanctions exemplaires
qui devront être prises alors quelle est
la solution
et bien travailler beaucoup plus sur le
maintien à domicile parce que la plus
grande partie des français s'ils le
peuvent
préfèrent rester chez eux mais pour
qu'ils puissent rester chez eux eh bien
il faut qu'ils en aient les moyens c'est
pour ça nous doublerons les crédits
d'impôt pour les emplois à domicile pour
permettre aux jeunes de faire garder
leurs enfants pour permettre aux
familles de faire garder leurs enfants
handicapés mais aussi pour permettre à
nos aînés de rester chez eux le plus
longtemps possible
[Applaudissements]
alors mes chers amis dans la nouvelle
france que je veux il faut aussi que
l'on libère les énergies
libérer les énergies libérer d'abord de
la bureaucratie libérer des normes
savais qu'à quatre cent mille normes qui
empêche les français de construire
d'entreprendre d'innover c'est pas
hasard celle ci a pas eu de vaccins
français alors qu'on a un entrepreneur
français qui a été créée moderna aux
états unis il n'y a pas eu de vaccins
français parce que la france elle est
trop bureaucratique et que quand on veut
innover on nous impose tellement
tellement tellement de procédures
tellement tellement d'autorisation qu'on
finit par baisser les bras donc il va
falloir
débureaucratiser c'est un combat que
nous menons avec les sénateurs il faudra
enlever toutes ces normes le chancelier
allemand monsieur holmes a prévenu qu'il
allait / 2 / de la durée des procédures
administratives dans son pays s'il y
arrive et que nous on ne fait pas un la
compétitivité de la france vous imaginez
bon on a déjà un rapport qui nous dit à
quel point on n'est pas compétitif vous
imaginez ce que ce serait si si on
laissait faire il va falloir prendre le
pouvoir va falloir libérer les énergies
et puis à falloir libérer le travail
parce que vous savez aujourd'hui il ya
un vrai doute des français sur le sens
de leur travail un vrai doute parce
qu'avec le prix de l'essence un vrai
doute parce qu'avec le coût de la vie un
vrai doute parce qu'avec les revenus
d'assistanat qui sont tellement élevés
ils se disent est ce que ça vaut
vraiment le coup d'aller travailler
alors moi je veux que le travail paye je
veux que le travail paye plus que
l'assistance je veux que tous les
français qui se lèvent cette france qui
travaille et bien elles se reconnaissent
et qu'elle sache qu'elle est comprise
parce qu'elle est le coeur battant de la
nouvelle france
et on va libérer le travail d'abord on
va augmenter de 10% les salaires sur le
quinquennat on commencera cet été avec 3
% de suppression de charges de charge de
cotisations retraite parce que je veux
que les français aient un geste un
signal pour leurs dix votre travail ça
vaut le coup et puis on leur permettra
on libérera totalement les heures
supplémentaires sans plafond on
permettra de transformer les rtt en
salaire et l'entreprise pourrons les
racheter sans charges sociales et puis
je vais libérer aussi le cumul emploi
retraite pour tous ceux qui le
souhaitent parce qu'on a besoin de la
force et de la vigueur de nos jeunes
retraités et puisque je parle de
retraités c'est indigne
c'est indigne que les retraites
aujourd'hui ne soit pas indexé sur
l'inflation et pire les complémentaires
soient désindexer c'est indigne que les
retraités étaient ainsi privés de
pouvoir d'achat pendant le quinquennat
d'emmanuel matheron mais c'est assez
logique mes chers amis c'est assez
logique pourquoi c'est parce qu'il n'a
pas eu le courage de réformer notre pays
il a pas eu le courage de faire la
réforme des retraites et sans réforme eh
bien il n'y a plus de pouvoir d'achat
des retraités donc nous ferons la
réforme des retraites nous la ferons
jusqu'à nous la ferons et les français
travailleront jusqu'à 65 ans sauf ceux
qui sont usés par le travail et grâce à
cette réforme nous pourrons à la fois
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités mais nous pourrons garantir à
tous les retraités qui ont travaillé
toute une vie une retraite au moins
égale au smic
[Applaudissements]
et puis grâce à cette réforme nous
pourrons aussi garantir aux femmes qui
n'ont pas eu de carrière complète parce
qu'elles ont dû élever des enfants parce
qu'elles ont aidé leurs conjoints à ces
femmes qui n'ont pas eu une carrière
complète nous garantiront une pension de
reversions non plus de 54% mais de 75%
et puis il ya une dernière dernier un
dernier sujet très sensible
c'est la question des enfants en
situation de handicap
beaucoup trop de nos retraités craignent
de l'essai après leur départ un enfant
handicapé ces retraités qui n'ont pas de
biens qui n'ont pas d'héritage et qui se
disent que va devenir notre enfant après
eh bien pour ses enfants nous aurons
nous leur garantiront qu'ils toucheront
la pension de reversions du dernier
parent survivant
comme ça leurs parents seront sera et
seront tranquilliser alors oui mes amis
va falloir faire des réformes oui il va
falloir dépenser moins dépenser mieux et
il va falloir travailler plus c'est les
vérités qui sont pas bonnes à entendre
beaucoup de français me disent oh là là
c'est pas populaire de dire ça faut
surtout pas y tire faut surtout pas dire
les choses qui fâchent il vaut mieux
dire comme emmanuel macron qu'on peut
continuer à faire des chèques qu'on peut
continuer à faire de la dette et que ça
ne se transformera jamais en impôts moi
je vous le dit emmanuel macron va
annoncer sa candidature
bah ils feraient mieux de présenter
l'addition
parce qu'avec emmanuel macron l'addition
ce sera après les élections
[Applaudissements]
alors oui voilà mes chers amis ce que je
voulais vous proposer comme premier
projet avant que nous ayons le temps
d'échanger ensemble puisque je crois que
c'est le format de ce soir que vous avez
envie de me poser des questions
peut-être même que vous les avez préparé
à l'avance mais je voudrais dire un
dernier petit mot sur quelque chose qui
va falloir qu'on protège qu'on protège
comme un trésor dans la nouvelle france
il va falloir qu'on protège notre
histoire et notre culture notre histoire
et notre culture par c'est parce que ce
sont elles qui font ce que nous sommes
alors oui ici sur la terre de clemenceau
sur la terre du maréchal de lattre
je veux qu'on se dise que nous ne devons
pas nous excuser d'avoir eu des ro la
france est belle notre histoire est
belle elle est lumineuse et moi j'accuse
emmanuel macron d'être tombé dans la
repentance et d'avoir accusé la france
d' un crime contre l'humanité qu'elle
n'a jamais commis
et je le dis oui il y a une culture
française et cette culture française
nous allons la transmettre à tous nos
jeunes dès l'école je veux que chaque
école est un projet artistique et
culturel
je veux qu'on protège notre patrimoine
je veux que dans la nouvelle france
notre culture rayonne et je veux surtout
que notre jeunesse soient fiers qu'elle
soit fière d'être française je veux que
cette jeunesse l ai pas peur je veux
qu'on l'accompagnent dans ses projets je
veux que cette jeunesse elle rayonne
cheveux que le nom de la france résonne
je veux aujourd'hui mes chers amis vous
emmener dans un projet de nouvelle
france vive la république et vive la
france
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est tellement vieux temple
naturel
[Applaudissements]
la parole est aux questions
la parole est aux questions de la salle
il a le micro est parti il ya un
monsieur qui l'a
oui bonjour
bonjour les problèmes sont souvent des
problèmes de gouvernance la france un
gros problème de gouvernance la
constitution de 58 a défini un régime
parlementaire il ya donc un président de
la république un premier ministre qui
n'est pas l'employé du président de la
république et à parlement aujourd'hui le
pouvoir est complètement déséquilibrée
aux mains du président de la république
et de ses conseillers le gouvernement
est devenu simplement un exécutant c'est
une évolution qui n'est pas nouvelle
mais s'est aggravée avec monsieur
sarkozy d'abord faut le dire et ensuite
avec monsieur macro donc aujourd'hui il
ya un problème de gouvernance qui fait
que les réformes que vous avez évoquées
ne peuvent pas se faire parce qu'un
homme seul ou une femme seul ne pourra
pas tout seul s'il n'a pas la légitimité
d'être appuyée sur une majorité
présidentielle au parlement est de
pouvoir négocier et avoir des décisions
qui soient un peu collective pouvoir
faire passer cette légitimité et donc la
constitution du général de gaulle de 58
avec un président qui fixe effectivement
les grandes orientations qui à la
stratégie mais un gouvernement qui
gouverne c'est l'article 20 de la
constitution et un premier ministre qui
dirige l'action du gouvernement et donc
la question que je voulais vous poser
est ce que vous avez l'intention si vous
êtes élus de respecter la constitution
alors
alors deux choses d'abord je pense que
nous avons une présidence
essentiellement bavarde tout a été dit
est d'ailleurs le contraire de tout
aussi puisqu'on a un président du zig
zag on l'a vu par exemple sur le
nucléaire
qui ferment des réacteurs qui ferment
enfin qui ferme fessenheim qui annonce
la fermeture de 14 réacteurs et puis qui
sous la pression de l'opposition et de
la montée des prix de l'énergie se
résout a finalement annoncé 6 e p r
supplémentaire donc on a un président
qui a beaucoup parlé mais qui n'a pas
été un hyper président comme l'était
nicolas sarkozy parce que nicolas
sarkozy est un hyper président mais tu
es sider et il faisait et je peux vous
dire que nous les ministres on avait une
sacrée feuille de route et on devait
rendre des comptes quasiment tous les
mois surtout donc ont été dirigés certes
par l'elysée plus que par matignon même
si françois fillon a énormément
a énormément travaillé à
concrétiser les engagements nicolas
sarkozy mais c'est vrai que le président
était assez était assez intrusif mais
emmanuel macron c'est pas ça qui se
passe il décide de tout mais il se passe
rien et c'est ça et ça s'est dit
complètement différent
là aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
il faut un président ou une présidente
vous avez compris que ces masses et ma
préférence il faut une présidente qui
sache décidé qu'ils sachent impulsé qui
a un programme qui soit complètement
ficelé vous savez que j'ai confiée à
bruno retailleau décrire les 100
premiers jours de mon mandat
pourquoi parce qu'il ya la conquête du
pouvoir mais il ya aussi son exercice
son exercice on s'est trop focalisé
depuis des années sur la conquête du
pouvoir alors oui
les beaux parleurs
les bonimenteurs oui certes ça peut
faire des voix d'ailleurs si vous voulez
le meilleur orateur 1 prenez mélenchon
mais aujourd'hui le sujet c'est qu'il
faut des acteurs il faut faire et donc
mon premier ministre sera
nécessairement une personnalité
expérimentée sera nécessairement un
grand politique et c'est lui qui va
mettre en mettre en musique le projet et
cela je m'y engage j'ajoute que j'ai
autour de moi et c'est ma force une
formidable équipe de france une équipe
de professionnels regardez les ils sont
là une équipe de professionnels ils
savent gérer sa dirigée ils ont dirigé
des régions des départements des villes
ils savent faire ils sauront faire parce
que les réformes qu'on va devoir faire
je peux vous dire ça va pas être facile
facile hein ça va même être demandé
beaucoup de courage de ténacité et
d'expérience donc c'est ça qu'on fera et
puis j'ai quelque chose dont je vous ai
pas parlé mais le référendum moi j'ai
pas peur du référendum et je considère
que le président de la république doit
on faire usage quand les français nous
disent il ya trop d'immigration eh bien
il faut les écouter quand ils nous
disent y'a trop d'insécurité il faut les
écouter quand ils nous disent on veut
une nation une et indivisible et on veut
que personne ne puisse prévaloir de son
origine ou de sa religion pour échapper
à la loi commune il faut les écouter et
il faut changer les textes or vous le
savez bien on a du mal à changer texte
le sénat passe des lois qui sont souvent
en retoquant au conseil constitutionnel
donc moi je redonnerai sa parole au
peuple de france et nous ferons des
référendums nous ferons des réformes
constitutionnelles sur
l'immigration mais aussi sur la sécurité
sur la laïcité
j'en ai pas parlé mais la laïcité pour
moi c'est un simon aujourd'hui on est
dans une terre qui est une terre
à la foi laïque et catholique avec deux
traditions mais vous savez bien
qu'aujourd'hui pour faire vivre ensemble
tous les français avec toutes leurs
croyances tout leurs convictions tout
leur origine eh bien il faut absolument
que la laïcité soit mise au coeur parce
que la laïcité c'est pas la négation des
religions c'est pas non plus c'est là le
respect du fait de croire ou de ne pas
croire mais la laïcité c'est surtout la
neutralité de l'espace public nous avons
besoin que l'espace public soit neutre
pour permettre l'émancipation de nos
enfants et de nos jeunes nous avons
besoin que l'espace public soit neutre
pour préserver les femmes aussi de
l'emprise et de la soumission voilà je
les dis dimanche dernier marianne n'est
pas une femme voilée
donc on a la liberté
mais il faut protéger nos enfants c'est
le port du voile à l'école interdit
c'est la burqa interdite dans l'espace
public et puis c'est comme les sénateurs
l'ont voté l'interdiction des signes
religieux dans les compétitions
sportives
là encore le gouvernement a failli ils
ont failli aux interdits ils ont refusé
de voter la loi que les sénateurs nous
proposait moi je pense que le sport doit
être préservée de toute interférence
voilà
donc référendum et référendum aussi
d'initiatives populaires parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons besoin aussi
que le peuple puisse prendre des
initiatives
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mesdames bonsoir messieurs
bonsoir valérie pécresse mon sort je
suis raphaël etienne j'ai 15 ans et j'ai
une question à vous poser à propos de
votre programme vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure et c'est je pense un point clé
du référendum d'initiative citoyenne ou
d'initiatives populaires comme certains
voudront l'apli c'est un outil qui est
je pense est essentielle à notre
démocratie
le général de gaulle en avait fait usage
du référendum à l'époque
pour parer à la barrière parlementaires
qui se présentait parfois
c'est un projet important qui peut
redonner à notre peuple un certain
pouvoir
cependant une organisation s'impose et
en effet il est complexe de faire
s'exprimer d'une seule voix des
personnes si différentes
comment donc s'organisera t-il et
comment sera choisi la question posée à
nos concitoyens
à questions très précises
réponse qui le sera un petit peu moins
parce qu'on est en train de concerter
justement avec les parlementaires pour
savoir comment est-ce qu'on passe d'un
référendum d'initiative partagée très
verrouillé où seuls les parlementaires
ce peuvent lancer l'initiative à un
référendum inverse où c'est les citoyens
qui lance l'initiative en proposant par
exemple une pétition en ligne et ensuite
il y aura une le parlement qui se
prononcera soit le sénat soit
l'assemblée qui se prononcera sur la
validité de la question posée et qui
permettra de la soumettre donc il y aura
un processus de d'initiative populaire
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
initiative parlementaire mais y aura
nécessairement un passage devant le
parlement pour vérifier effectivement
que la question posée entre bien dans
les questions qui doivent être posées
parce qu'il n'est pas question que ce
référendum d'initiative populaire ne
viennent polluer l'action du
gouvernement ça ne peut donc pas porté
sur des textes qui sont aujourd'hui en
discussion au parlement où des lois qui
aurait été juste votée donc ce sera sur
un certain nombre de sujets et bien
spécifiques sur lesquels on pourra
lancer ce référendum
bonsoir madame pécresse juste une
question finale sur le référendum vous
savez que nous sommes aussi en vendée
mais près de la loire atlantique nous
avons eu alors est ce que c'est vraiment
un référendum je me pose encore la
question
[Applaudissements]
voilà nous avons eu un un positionnement
des habitants de loire atlantique
notamment sur notre dame des landes
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour la parole
des citoyens et quand on nous demande
notre avis l'intérêt c'est que le plus
forts l'emportent et même si c'est pas
que ce soit ma conviction ou pas sur le
résultat final du référendum moi je veux
savoir demain et je pense que j'en suis
sûr mais j'espère que vous allez me
confirmer ce soir que le résultat du
référendum seront appliquées et que la
boîte des citoyens soient entendus merci
absolument
mois les restera d'hommes qu'on
organisera
je respecterai leur résultat
contrairement à emmanuel macron à notre
dame des landes parce que quoi qu'on
pense du résultat vous l'avez dit madame
c'est la démocratie qui s'est exprimé et
quand la démocratie s'exprime c'est
sacré
[Applaudissements]
question ya des questions madame la
présidente bonsoir ici ce sera comme ça
ici comme beaucoup de retraités j'ai
travaillé toute ma vie pour payer ma
maison est ce que vous envisagez de
modifier les droits de succession ah oui
j'ai même oublié d'en parler
[Applaudissements]
je veux être la candidate de la
transmission transmission des savoirs
transmission de la culture transmission
de notre histoire transmission de nos
modes de vie mais aussi transforme
transmission nos patrimoines et je veux
un choc de transmission parce qu'il ya
beaucoup
d'aînés qui aujourd'hui ont accumulé de
l'epargne pendant la crise qu vite parce
que on a été confiné donc je veux que ce
patrimoine puissent circuler auprès des
enfants auprès des petits enfants et
donc je vais raccourcir le délai
aujourd'hui on peut transmettre jusqu'à
100000 euros tous les 15 ans ce sera
tous les six ans comme ça ça incitera à
redonner maintenant aux enfants aux
petits enfants cinquante mille euros aux
neveux et nièces aux frères et soeurs je
veux un choc de transmission je veux
mettre le pied à l'étrier de notre
jeunesse et puis pour les successions
moi je veux que 95% des français soit
exonéré de droits de succession pour
qu'ils puissent transmettre
le fruit du travail de toute une vie qui
a été tellement imposez vous savez on
est champion du monde des impôts
champion du monde donc tout ce que vous
avez gagné et bien a été déjà très
largement imposée donc je veux que 95%
des droits de succession soit supprimée
et j'ajoute que pour les pme puisque
vous savez que malheureusement la
désindustrialisation a continué pendant
cinq ans le mandat des manuels macron
vous le savez 85 milliards de déficit de
la balance commerciale
ce chiffre dit tout ce chiffre c'est le
drame français ça veut dire que tous les
chiens qu'on vous a fait c'est pour
acheter des biens importés voilà et
c'est une france dépendantes aujourd'hui
donc il faut réindustrialiser pour
réindustrialiser il faut s'appuyer sur
ce tissu extraordinaires que nous avons
de pme et notamment de pme familiales et
de tei familiale d'entreprises de taille
intermédiaire familiale et c'est le
tissu économique de la vendée donc ce
que je veux c'est que là aussi pour la
transmission des pme familiale si
les les repreneurs les héritiers
s'engage à garder pendant un certain
nombre d'années
leurs titres de l'entreprise eh bien on
puisse avoir 95 % de défiscalisation
pour qu'on puisse transmettre les
entreprises familiales c'est comme ça
que les allemands ont constitué leur
tissu économique c'est comme ça que
l'industrie restera française et qu'on
se fera pas piller à chaque succession
nos petites pépites
bonjour madame pécresse bonjour jeune
homme il ya beaucoup de jeunes dans
cette salle
beaucoup de jeunes motivés alors j'ai 17
ans ma question se tournait au niveau de
la confiance envers les jeunes puisque
disons que notre famille politique est
connue par nos détracteurs pour être une
famille qui ne respectent pas forcément
ses engagements qui ne respectent pas
forcément les promesses qu'elle tient au
niveau des détracteurs bien sûr et donc
non j'en fais partie donc
à ce niveau là donc il me paraissait
intéressant
de me demander ce que vous ce que vous
répondiez en fait aux jeunes qui
n'avaient plus cette confiance envers
les politiques à cause de certains qui
les ont trahis après des promesses de
rêve parfois on vous accuse de un petit
peu sortir le portefeuille qu'est ce que
vous répondez justement à ça eh bien je
leur réponds que je suis président d'une
région je suis président d'une région et
dans cette région j'ai tenu mes
engagements
et si je les avais pas tenu je n'aurais
pas été réélu et c'est ce qu'on peut
prouver c'est que quand on est réélu
c'est que les électeurs vous font
confiance donc je leur dis moi je fais
ce que je dis et je dis ce que je fais
mais sur la jeunesse j'ai oublié de
parler d'un projet qui me tient à coeur
qui est la banque des jeunes et cette
banque des jeunes c'est une banque que
je veux faire avec les réseaux de
bancaire est une garantie de l'état pour
permettre aux jeunes de briser l'
autocensure parce que dans beaucoup de
départements notamment dans les
départements ruraux on a trop de jeunes
qui ne poursuivent pas leurs études
après le bac et ils poursuivent pas
leurs études après le bac pourquoi parce
que ça coûte cher d'aller vivre à nantes
ça coûte cher d'aller vers à bordeaux ou
à paris et donc ben
il hésite et finalement ils finissent
pas restez pas rester dans leur village
ou pas rester dans leur territoire
et ils osent pas donc moi ce que je veux
c'est pouvoir financer leurs études et
qu' il ne rembourse que quand ils
gagneront un certain niveau de salaire
pourquoi pour les rassurer parce que on
peut aussi
tenter on peut aussi à un moment donné
avoir des difficultés donc je veux
qu'ils puissent emprunter dans la
sérénité pour pouvoir mener ce projet
d'étude et c'est important j'ai un choc
de transmission pour les jeunes qui ont
des parents qui peuvent les aider mais
je veux aussi cette banque des jeunes
pour les jeunes qui n'ont pas d'héritage
bonsoir madame pécresse bonsoir à toutes
et à tous je suis ludovic montoro j'ai
46 ans j'ai construit à rocheservière il
ya douze ans j'ai fait une maison avec
un terrain de 500 m² avec 55 euros le
mètre carré aujourd'hui dix ans après
dans la même commune hilla à 100 euros
le mètre carré est aujourd'hui sur la
côte on voit que les jeunes issus de
saint-gilles de tous ne pas pas faire
construire l'immobilier augmente le
pouvoir d'achat augmente monsieur bacon
aujourd'hui il me feria même pour le
handicap même pour l'apprentissage même
pour l'école votre discours il est très
bien et je voudrais que vous aidez vous
aider tout le monde parce que le pouvoir
d'achat les produits alimentaires
augmentent les jeunes d'aujourd'hui j'en
vois à mon âge qui sont restos du coeur
qui il était chez leurs parents qui
vivaient et aujourd'hui c'est incroyable
de voir ça qu'est ce que vous allez
faire et je pense que vous êtes la
première
dame foot
vous savez il ya ya ya en france des
tenants de la décroissance
la décroissance c'est cette idéologie
qui dit que et bien pour sauver la
planète il faut plus rien faire il faut
plus rien toucher il faut plus prendre
l'avion c'est vrai faut plus prendre sa
voiture faut pas prendre non plus le
métro parce que ça fait les gars et que
voilà et que donc du coup et que donc du
coup bah ça ça ça ça empiète sur les
territoires les territoires agricoles
donc des mobilités décroissance bon la
france ne supporterait pas la
décroissance et moi je le dis je ne
poserai jamais l'écologie à la qualité
de vie la qualité de vie c est bien logé
le mal logement est un drame pour les
familles c'est un drame pour nos jeunes
et c'est un drame pour les familles et
avec le confinement on a vu trop de
problématiques du mal logement et le
problème c'est que si on construit pas
eh bien du coup un certain nombre de
personnes garderont les logements qui
devraient aller aux plus démunis donc en
plus c'est très anti sociale ne pas
construire parce que il faut un parcours
résidentiel il faut que ceux qui ont les
moyens puissent devenir propriétaire
et puis il faut que ceux qui n'ont pas
les moyens puissent devenir locataire et
puis ceux qui ont moins de moyens encore
puisse tenir le qatar sociale il faut
des parcours résidentiels moi je
revendique de reprendre ce beau projet
d'une france de propriétaires alors
comment on fait pour les jeunes mais il
faut qu'on construise plus et pour ça il
faut faire confiance au maire m.ahyi r
es parce que c'est eux qui savent
comment on dessine une ville et c'est
eux qui seront si on peut construire à
tel ou tel endroit et si c'est bien il
faut leur redonner ce pouvoir
aujourd'hui malheureusement on a créé
une norme qui s'appelle le zéro
artificialisation net qui dans les dans
les métropoles est une très bonne norme
moi je les applique chez moi en ile de
france parce qu'il faut protéger les
terres agricoles parce qu'il faut
protéger les espaces naturels mais c'est
une norme qui ne doit pas s'appliquer
j'allais dire arbitrairement dans un
territoire plus rurales il faut que le
maire puisse décider du visage de sa
ville avec son conseil municipal et il
faut qu'ils puissent continuer à
construire il faut qu'ils puissent
continuer à construire pour pouvoir pour
que le logement ne coûte pas trop cher
et puis il faut qu'ils puissent aussi
rénover les centres bourgs là aussi dans
l'app dans la table ronde que j'ai eu
cet après midi avec des professionnels
du bâtiment on me dit qu'il faut aussi
qu'on aide à la déconstruction des
ruines dans les centres bourgs qu'on
aide à la reconstruction des maisons
donc sur tous ces sujets là moi j'ai un
engagement je vais prendre un engagement
500000 construction et rénovation par an
c'est ça l'objectif qu'il faut atteindre
pour pouvoir lutter contre le
mal-logement et permettre à nos jeunes
de pouvoir se loger aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron c'est 360 mille logements par an
c'est beaucoup trop peu et si on
continue comme ça aujourd'hui on vous
parle de la hausse des prix de l'énergie
mais demain le vrai gros problème que
nous aurons ce sera l'impossibilité pour
les français de se loger et c'est déjà
commencé
et ici en vendée vous avez énormément de
télétravailleurs vous avez énormément de
gens de la ville qui viennent pour pour
occuper les maisons vous le savez il
faut qu'on préserve le pouvoir d'achat
des jeunes vendeurs
et j'ajoute que je ferai après à taux
zéro sur toute la france c'est quoi le
prêt à taux zéro le prêt à taux zéro
vous savez c'est un instrument qui
permet aux jeunes d'avoir un apport
initial quand ils n'en n'ont pas et dans
l'est dans lego aujourd'hui c'est que
dans les zones tendues qu'on fait du
prêt à taux zéro moi je veux qu'on fasse
dans toute la france parce que je veux
que la ruralité puissent en bénéficier
je veux que tous nos bourgs tous nos
villages puissent vivre
[Applaudissements]
nous pensons madame pécresse bon je suis
étudiant donc augustin je viens de
nantes je suis étudiant en gestion de
patrimoine master 1 ma question c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya plupart de nos
compatriotes
se plaignent banques notamment de la
fiscalité on peut de plus en plus de
fiscalité vous pouvez voir que la csg
depuis des années des années ne cesse
d'augmenter quel serait votre mesure en
fait d'entendre quelles
conditions pouvaient vous comptez vous
alléger la fiscalité valeur en france où
la grosse question
moi j'ai plutôt j'ai plutôt axé comme
maintenant on est fiscalisé à la source
j'ai plutôt axé ma ma priorité sur la
hausse des salaires en enlevant des
charges sociales sur les salaires donc
c'est que c'est ça ce que je vais faire
enlever des cotisations retraites sur
les salaires pour pouvoir augmenter les
salaires de 3% et puis ensuite je
baisserais les impôts de production des
entreprises pour les rendre compétitives
pour concret encore plus d'emplois en
france c'est indispensable vous avez vu
le rapport qui sortit ya quelques jours
nous ne sommes plus compétitifs par
rapport aux autres pays et c'est pour ça
qu évidemment on exporte moins et qu'on
n'est pas on n'est pas la grande
puissance économique que nous devons
être être une grande puissance
économique c'est important pour créer de
l'emploi mais c'est aussi important pour
le rayonnement international de la
france vous avez vu que monsieur poutine
il a attendu que le premier ministre
allemand viennent le voir pour faire la
désescalade en ukraine quand emmanuel
macron est venu le voir
0 résultats bah oui mais c'est parce que
les russes c'est comme les chinois
aujourd'hui où les américains ils
respectent plus les allemands que nous
et ils respectent plus les allemands
parce que c'est un peuple qui a une
grande puissance économique et dont les
approvisionnements sont importants pour
les pays donc il faut qu'on baisse les
impôts de production des entreprises
donc j'ai promis déjà 10 milliards de
baisses d'impôts de production mais il y
en aura davantage en fonction de la
politique salariale que les entreprises
mèneront mais moi je veux qu'on ramène
les impôts de production des entreprises
françaises dans la moyenne de l'union
européenne et aujourd'hui on a 35
milliards d'euros de différence mais
pour faire ça il faut faire des
économies des économies chers amis alors
je sais on va me dire quand je dis qu'il
faut supprimer 200 mille postes de
fonctionnaires on me dit oulala faut
surtout pas tous les postes sont
importants mais c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai chaque personne est importante mais
les postes ne sont pas importants les
postes ça veut rien dire si vous avez on
n'arrête pas d'ouvrir des bureaux en
france on ouvre des bureaux on ferme des
écoles en ouvre des bureaux on ferme des
lits à l'hôpital
moi je veux ouvrir des lits je veux
ouvrir des écoles et je veux fermer des
bureaux vous savez on a des agences
partout et tout le monde fait tout
l'état la région le département alors on
va décentraliser on va décentraliser
pour économiser pour plus avoir de
doublons voilà et comme ça on pourra
effectivement supprimer un certain
nombre de postes et récupérer cet argent
pour créer
cinquante mille nouveaux postes
on supprime 200000 gens créent cinquante
mille 50 mille d'en protéger éduquer
soigner cinquante mille dans l'éducation
la justice
et puis le soin l'hôpital et puis ça
permettra aussi ses économies de mieux
rémunérer les fonctionnaires parce que
s'il ya moins de fonctionnaires vous
qu'il soit moins rêver mieux rémunéré
pendant six à moins de fonctionnaires il
faut qu'il soit mieux rémunéré et puis
ça permettra aussi de baisser les impôts
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle elodie j'ai 23 ans parce
que les concours de la fonction publique
d'état donc je suis futurs
fonctionnaires je m'interroge justement
sur le fait que vous vouliez supprimer
ces deux cent mille fonctionnaires
j'aimerais bien savoir qu'est ce que
vous allez en faire et oui alors c'est
200000 postes voila j'aimerais bien
savoir si vous allez les réformés ou
qu'est ce que vous allez faire de ces
postes et deuxième petite question on
dit souvent que la france compte trop de
fonctionnaires 5 millions de
fonctionnaires en france c'est pas plus
qu'en allemagne ou chez nos voisins
européens
et je voulais savoir si le problème si
vous ne pensiez pas finalement que le
problème ce n'est pas tendre de
supprimer des fonctionnaires mais plutôt
un manque d'efficacité et un manque de
formation oui alors moi je supprime pas
les personnes je ne remplace pas je ne
remplace pas les personnes qui partent
en retraite c'est pas tout à fait pareil
mais si vous voulez je vous donne des
exemples vous savez il ya 2010 chez des
deux entreprises en france 2000 2010
chez ça veut dire que les entreprises
françaises elles ont deux mille endroits
où elles peuvent demander des
subventions ça fait peut-être un peu
beaucoup donc le sujet aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il faut il faut qu'on fasse cette
réforme de l'état il faut qu'on dépense
mieux l'argent donc effectivement il y
aura des suppressions de postes et moi
je les fais dans ma région j'ai supprimé
15 structures j'ai récupéré tous les
agents et je les ai réorienter dans
d'autres métiers mais on aura toujours
besoin de fonctionnaires le service
civique c'est un supplément d'âme
simplement il faut que ce service public
d'abord ils soient plus efficaces la
notion de performance publique c'est pas
un gros mot la performance publique
quand vous demander une autorisation à
l'état il faut l'autorisation elle
arrive vite donc il va falloir aussi
numériser va falloir aussi digitaliser
et ça et ça ça permettra de faire une
meilleure administration
donc ne soyez pas inquiète pour votre
avenir chère mademoiselle
vous aurez vous aurez beaucoup plus de
responsabilités si l'état marche mieux
savais dans ma région je vous dis j'ai
j'ai supprimé les des structures qui
étaient en doublon et ben du coup les
agents aujourd'hui ils ont beaucoup plus
de responsabilités et ils sont très
heureux parce que en fait
on est plus heureux quand on est agent
public quand on a une belle mission à
remplir pas quand il ya trois bureaux
qui font la même chose à trois endroits
différents donc vous verrez ce sera ce
sera aussi très belles réformes pour
vous
et puis si on supprime pas de poste on
pourra pas revaloriser les traitements
bonjour madame pécresse je m'appelle à
raphaël bodin lehman j'ai 16 ans je vais
bientôt en avoir 17 et j'ai une question
pour vous sur votre avis sur
internationalement par exemple votre
avis sur l'otan
aussi est ce que vous comptez faire un
rapprochement avec un rapprochement
politique avec la russie ou la chine est
votre avis sur le lieu aussi voilà on
est parti pour une heure
non sur le temps sur le temps moi je
pense alors c'est vrai que certains
certains ont dit avec ce que les états
unis nous ont fait en australie il
faudrait quitter le commandement intégré
de l'otan bon moi je fais pas ça parce
que je pense qu'on peut pas sur réagir
comme ça
ah
j'allais dire un coup de canif dans le
contrat mais bon voilà on choisit une
alliance nicolas sarkozy à des as a
décidé de rentrer dans le commandement
intégré de l'otan on y est rentré
maintenant on va pas en ressortir parce
que y'a geste qui nous déplaît on est
dans l'otan c'est notre alliance c'est
une alliance importante mais dans l'otan
on est on est à lier et pas alignés et
dans l'otan nous gardons il faut le
savoir notre souveraineté
nationale sur l'emploi des forces moi ce
que je voudrais dans le temps c'est que
le lien plier européen petit puis secret
est je pense que les états unis de joe
biden sont prêts à ce que l'europe
s'émancipe un petit peu dans l'otan et
prennent un peu plus sur ses épaules la
charge de sa sécurité
ça m'amène à votre deuxième question oui
je pense que emmanuel macron n'aurait
pas dû laisser passer trois années sans
aller parler à vladimir poutine la
russie il faut lui parler tous les ans
alors ça veut pas dire qu'on les croie à
chaque fois qu'il parle mais ça veut
dire qu'on nous ait un dialogue un
dialogue qui est quand même aussi basé
sur une certes certains certaine
lucidité un certain rapport de forces
c'est vrai mais un dialogue tous les ans
construit et puis sur la question de la
sécurité en europe ce que je crois c'est
qu' il est temps aujourd'hui de faire
une grande conférence sur la sécurité de
l'europe une grande conférence dans
laquelle il y aura l'union européenne
tous les états de l'union européenne
dans laquelle il y aura la russie dans
lequel il pourrait y avoir la grande
bretagne qu'elle pourrait même y avoir
la turquie et que l'on se mette autour
de la table pour décider comment on
protège
l'europe nous mêmes et comment on
sécurise l'europe ça s'appelle l'europe
de l'atlantique à l'oural et c'était un
projet du général de gaulle
alors ça veut pas dire évidemment que je
fais à rentrer la russie dans l'union
européenne ni la turquie on vous avez
bien compris qui ait pas d'ambiguïté
s'agit d'une alliance pour la sécurité
de l'europe en revanche sur l'union
européenne
moi ce que je veux c'est une france
forte dans une europe puissante et
aujourd'hui on à emmanuel macron qui
pratiquent la diplomatie de la posture
donne des leçons et il y parle
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin d'une
diplomatie d'influencé c'est pas du tout
pareil une diplomatie d'influencé une
diplomatie qui défend les intérêts de la
france en europe c'est ce que font les
allemands c'est ce que font les
britanniques et on en parlait avec avec
les pêcheurs on en parle avec les
agriculteurs c'est ce que font les
espagnols aussi beaucoup mieux que nous
donc aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
d'être fort et d'être puissant en europe
ça veut dire aussi envoyé des jeunes
talents de la fonction publique d'état à
bruxelles il faut qu'on ait beaucoup
plus de français à bruxelles et puis il
faut qu'on défende nos intérêts nos
intérêts notre industrie de défense le
nucléaire
il faut qu'on défende la taxe carbone
aux frontières une vraie taxe carbone
parce que pour l'instant ses 800
millions de taxe carbone aux frontières
c'est pas assez au départ dans
l'ambition initiale des manuels macron
mais comme toujours ça fait pschitt
c'était 15 milliards d'euros la taxe
carbone aux frontières de l'europe c'est
beaucoup plus important parce que 15
milliards d'euros de taxe carbone ça
veut dire quoi c'est à dire qu'on se met
vraiment à taxer les produits importés
qui sont polluants et que on rééquilibre
au profit du fabriqué en europe du
fabriqué en france
les règles du jeu et nous comme on on a
les normes les plus élevées qu'on n'en a
plus que tout le monde
cette taxe carbone sera un atout pour
nous et moi je le dis à nos agriculteurs
je n'accepte plus que nous importions en
france des produits
alimentaires étrangers qui ne respectent
pas nos normes environnementales ça
n'est pas possible
bruno retailleau disais tout à l'heure
c'est un rapport du sénat que je crois
que j'ai bien retenu mono un jour et
demi sur cinq un jour et demi sur cinq
ne mangeons des produits étrangers et un
quart de ces produits ne sont pas
produits selon les normes que nous
imposons à nos agriculteurs
ça n'est pas normal alors c'est pas la
faute des français c'est pas la faute
des français les français ils ont des
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat donc ils
achètent les produits premier prix mais
nous nous devons absolument
imposer les circuits courts des produits
locaux dans nos cantines alors ce sera
un peu plus cher peut-être qu'il faudra
faire des chèques alimentaires pour les
personnes les plus déshérités pour
qu'elles puissent avoir accès à une
alimentation de qualité mais je le dis
il faut qu'on puisse
produire français savoure et français et
c'est fabriqué en france c'est très
important il n'y a pas de grands pays
sans grande industrie la pâte grands
pays sans grande agriculture
alors comme il est déjà tard nous allons
prendre la dernière question
bonsoir madame pécresse
tout d'abord je dois vous remettre un
courrier qui est je vais me présenter
francis bernard président de l'iaaf de
l'avant dit donc udaf c'est union
départementale des associations
familiales j'ai rencontré la présidente
de l'unaf ya pas longtemps madame blanc
donc je vais mettre un courrier donc
c'est une question que vous pouvez
étudier
c'est une question sur les mesures à doc
mineurs et mai nord
qu'est ce que vous souhaiteriez pour les
mineurs non accompagnés
je vous laisse là regardez votre
courrier d'accord je regarderai donc
pour la question depuis plus de 10 ans
les familles sont les plus grandes
perdantes de la politique familiale
défavorable donc baisse de la natalité
peu de visibilité inquiétudes quant au
soutien financier de l'état
une question vous avez pas parlé donc
l'augmentation dès violences au sein des
couples dont les enfants sont des
victimes marquer durablement bref la
liste est longue en quelques mots
pourriez-vous nous partager votre vision
de la politique familiale en mesure de 2
en mesure de redonner confiance et
espoir aux familles alors j'ai déjà
parlé effectivement de ma politique
d'augmentation des allocations
familiales et d'allocations familiales
dès le premier enfant je souhaite aussi
qu'on travaille notamment en milieu
rural sur un service public de la petite
enfance alors je sais que le conseil
économique et social est en train de
regarder ce point il faut comme en
matière de santé qu'on puisse mettre
toutes les collectivités autour de la
table et tous les acteurs pour essayer
de permettre la garde d'enfants et
d'augmenter l'offre de garde d'enfants
notamment dans les territoires ruraux
c'est très important si on veut y faire
revenir des familles la politique
familiale pour moi c'est aussi l'école
c'est aussi le souhait tian scolaire
gratuit pour les enfants qui donc pas
les moyens parce que vous le savez
l'école est gratuite mais il ya des
inégalités pour l'argent entre ceux qui
peuvent payer les petits cours à leurs
enfants et ceux qui peuvent pas les
payer donc ce sera aussi ce soutien
scolaire gratuit ce sera là le
rétablissement des bourses au mérite et
je le dis pour les enfants bacheliers
mention très bien elles ont été
supprimées par najat vallaud belkacem
qui avait eu cette phrase terrible avait
dit elle avait dit mais si l'on mention
très bien ils n'ont pas besoin de bourse
bassi ainsi au contraire au contraire
ils sont notre fierté son leur fierté de
leurs familles la fierté de leur lycée
la fierté de leur village ou de leur
ville ils doivent pouvoir aller faire
les études de leur choix de leur choix
donc là dessus on aura on aura une
politique qui sera une politique
vraiment dead et d'appui
sur les familles donc je vous ai parlé
aussi du prêt à taux zéro du bas est
réel et solidaire aussi que je voudrais
faire pour qu'on puisse devenir
propriétaire sans acheter le terrain
mais juste en achetant le foncier
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire encore
sur la famille que je ne vous ai pas
encore dit
alors par rapport aux violences
conjugales oui très important par
rapport aux violences conjugales et
intrafamiliales
moi je veux un parquet spécialisé parce
que vous le savez les républicains ont
fait voter une loi très intéressante qui
a été adopté à l'unanimité
qui dit que les ordonnances de
protection doivent être signés dans les
six jours mais pas du tout du tout
respectée donc il faut qu'on ait des
parquet spécialisé qui jugent idéalement
dans les 24 48 heures les ordonnances de
protection qui les prononcent très vite
parce qu'on sait que 85% des femmes qui
vont décédées sous les coups de leur
compagnon de leur ex compagnon avait
porté plainte avant 85% donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut absolument que la
société réagissent à ce phénomène avant
et puis je voudrais vous parler un petit
peu aussi les familles monoparentales
comme on dit familles monoparentales
c'est en 90 sous % des femmes seules
avec des enfants des mamans solos pour
ces mamans les pensions alimentaires
qu'elles reçoivent pour l'éducation de
leurs enfants
sont incluses dans leurs revenus ça peut
leur faire perdre beaucoup de droit à
des aides à la prime d'activité à des
appels à des aides au logement moi je
défiscalisent ray ces aides ces pensions
alimentaires parce que on sait quand on
se sépare ceva % le coût de la vie en
plus cinq ans prend tout de suite et les
femmes sont toujours les grandes
perdantes et donc je pense qu'il faut
les aider à assurer la responsabilité de
leurs de leur famille
voilà et sur les les différentes
familles moi je tiens à dire aussi que
je je suis viscéralement contre la
gestation pour autrui parce que c'est la
marchandisation du corps des femmes
et moi je suis contre la société du tout
marchand moi je souhaite aujourd'hui que
que dans la société dans laquelle nous
vivons le corps humain les les organes
du corps humain tout ça ne puisse pas
faire l'objet d'une location ni d'un
agent
[Applaudissements]
chers amis il va falloir conclure
il va falloir conclure alors oui la
france la france des mois qui vient va
être une france qui aura envie de
liberté
qui aura envie
voilà de tourner une page alors moi je
vous dis les temps il est temps de
tourner la page emmanuel macron il est
temps
il est temps aujourd'hui de
redonner le pouvoir à une équipe qui
trace un sillon droit pas une équipe qui
zigzague pas une équipe qui dit à chacun
ce qu'il a envie d'entendre pas une
équipe par un président
caméléon qui est systématiquement dans
le plaire et jamais dans le faire alors
ne lui donnait pas un mandat de plus les
amis cinq ans c'était trop et dix ans ce
sera trop tard merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]